I'm going to talk about the hobby
project of mine called as well and what
I call a scientific game engine and I'm
going to use it today to build an
autopilot for a spaceship but just it's
a small disclaimer given that pretty
much every talk here seems to be about
machine learning there's no machine
learning in this one so if you're keen
on one that is probably not to talk
nevertheless so as a motivation is I've
always been bit amused about software
engineers and lately was about data
scientists because it's fairly easy for
them to acquire skills in their area so
all you have to usually do is find the
software that does put any doing find
the tutorial practice a bit and then
rinse repeat so it's very accessible
everybody can do it if they want to but
if you are an engineer but not a
saucepan Cheniere so if you belong to
the kind of engineers who built for
instance a mass robot or a reusable
rocket or a self-driving car or an
airport luggage handling system then how
do you acquire the skills for these kind
to solve these kind of problems because
clearly a Mars rover for instance it is
not going to be a web app so yeah you
need to have there some kind of real
hardware moving somewhere around in the
real world and ideally it ought to also
make sense of its environment without
crashing and as a the case study as I
mentioned earlier I thought what would
it take to build an autopilot for a
spaceship for instance so and turns out
they do not need that much so what you
need is they are right now where I would
like to be you need to have some control
over the engine so to move in some more
or less intelligent way to where you
would like to end up and of course you
need the spaceship and that's your
problem right there because you do not
have a spaceship and you cannot buy one
on amazon you might be able to buy one
on ebay but even if you could buy one on
ebay it tends to be a tad bit on the
expensive side so if you happen to
purchase one you probably wouldn't use
it to experiment with your autopilot
so in a computer game on the other hand
the spaceship is free everybody can have
one doesn't cost anything easy to
experiment and you can crash it as often
as you like so computer game seems to be
rougher the way to go the problem with a
classical computer game or more
particularly the engine that drives them
is that they were built for
entertainment not for realistic
simulations of the physics and that
makes them more or less the right tool
but not quite simply because the design
is usually here towards running on a
single computer it's very monolithic and
they're cutting every corner that they
can in particular about the physics
simulation just because it would like
too much are they available CPU cycles
to immersive gameplay store usually
visualization or audio effects and that
simply let me to the crash mobile it
take to build something like a game
engine but there was built purely for
proper large-scale physical simulations
so something they would not be
monolithic something we can actually use
in a scientific context as well and so I
thought it should be distributed right
from the start it should have a network
API only so that every language that can
make a network connection can actually
interact with the whole engine which
means it's a language agnostic and where
the no corners cut when it comes to the
physics toric really simulate more less
arbitrarily large into arbitrarily
complex physical systems and that is
what I was trying to do with as well it
used to be a proof of concept and
slightly outgoing there slowly out
throwing the proof of concept stage for
now and yeah what I would like to show
now is a simple life name of how I could
look for this magnificent spaceship not
the prettiest one I've ever seen but if
we do for our purposes so simple cube
with six thrusters in order to move it
in the three dimensions and the question
is how difficult is it now to build an
autopilot for something like this so and
if the code of live demos are with me
then we should
okie dokie so this is the simple setup
so don't worry about the code here and
that's what is going on in detail is not
that important so the first cell is
simply boilerplate and importing stuff
in particular importing a particular
class called piloted Ellis client which
is a wrap around the normal client just
to make this presentation a bit more
seamless and executing this nothing much
happens other than that the spatially
moved to the middle so that's fine and
the first demo if you want is simply to
specify and a particular initial
velocity and all you should see is move
the ship moving I see the ship moving so
in itself is not very stunning but the
point to highlight here is that they
have two individual components so one is
purely the visualization side which in
this case runs in a browser and if I
gave you my IP address you could see
exactly the same scene I'm not going to
give you my IP address but you could and
on the left side you have your standard
connection to your typical tools that we
would use in this case and I pies
notebook but those two components they
run completely independent of each other
so in the background there's the entire
s really start running that takes care
of the magic if you want and you simply
connect to it from in this case Python
and you connect to it in this case why
are babe viewer but both of those
components are purely optional and or
that this program did was so that set in
the initial velocity and the neva 20
milliseconds it sampled the position and
you simply get a plot here so since it
moved in different velocities in
different dimensions you get a you see
how the spaceship moves so fairly
straightforward nothing fancy here and
now moving on to the controller which is
exactly the same program as we had
before it just has these few additional
lines so again you don't have to you
don't need to know anything about
control theory anything the basic
principle that I'm that's going to
happen here is they all do is compute
the arrow which is simply difference
between your current position and your
desired position and then based on this
error you try to apply force but the
thrusters in order to move the spaceship
so that eventually it reaches the
desired position and how we do that that
is subject to control theory and there
are more or less smart ways to do this
and then this presentation is only going
to be a half-decent autopilot but it
will work so I'm for the first demo it
would simply be a purely proportional
controller and that simply means we take
the arrow we amplify with some random
factor here and then see what happens
and so what you can see here slide a bit
of visual feedback that's part of what
this pi data class that i mentioned
earlier does so they don't have to coat
it manually here and you can see how the
spaceship it ought to reach position
form but it clearly over short and boys
moving back so you can contemplate that
may be what you simply need is a bit
more coming out of the Boosters and the
second so maybe if we simply added a
deleter symbol here
so the same thing just with a stronger
force and this time it would still not
reach an equilibrium if you think about
that for a second it becomes very
obvious why that is so because for as
long as you have to the left of the
desired position you just keep pushing
to the right and vice versa and really
what you should be doing is slowly
slowing down as your approach so again
I'm not going to bore you with the
details of how and to build controllers
here and just suffice to say that if you
pick the right values here then you can
build the control that it does actually
very well and you can have again and see
that visualized in your 3d view which
you can freely zoom around if you want
to and we should see how it is now
actually does move to the desired
position and this is really all you need
in order to build an autopilot so in
this case it's exactly the same program
again but I've replaced the loop that we
had before with a simple call to this
controller method which does exactly the
piece of code that we saw before and
this now simply follow us a couple of
waypoints so this is how I would specify
your autopilot going from point 1 to
point 2 2 point 3 and so on and in this
case I simply specify the waypoints
actually moving around is obstacle here
the board of cubes moves up then we'll
move a bit further to the right and
eventually down again
okie dokie so that is one way to get to
the desired position here now another
way would be this it's it will work and
we still reach the final position but
unless you have very good insurance on
your spaceship which is probably not the
kind of way that you that he would like
it to take and this is of course where
all the engineering comes into place
yeah so how do you string together the
controller it moves to spatially from A
to B and connected to smart decisions
about how to avoid an obstacle of course
and this is where I don't so yeah this
is where you could start introducing
something like twenty cents machine
learning tools someone just so they have
an honorable mention of it in the talk
to find a smart way around obstacles so
I would know how to do them but maybe
someone will and a very similar problem
just slightly more pronounced is when
the board is not static but when you
really have like say a field of
asteroids in this case where you have to
move your ship through that asteroid
field without it ideally crashing
against any asteroids that is an even
it's a problem that's even are obviously
because you have to track those
asteroids and you have to find out where
to set the Bayport may point in between
and move through them so highly it's
really getting fairly non-trivial but it
still would be a lot of cheating in
voice because right now you could simply
ask the engine where those asteroids are
but in real life you cannot do that in
real life you would have to somehow in
fear where those asteroids are based on
some sense or feedback for instance you
could have some camera so like now we
have a virtual camera that when does the
scene here we could also render the
scene from the view of the cube say and
if you render that one you get an image
and if you have several cameras you
might get several images you can put
that into some image processing library
for preprocessing you could feed that to
your machine learning tool chain if you
feel like and try to fear from that or
try to learn from that where the objects
are more kind of
they are and maybe just in fearing from
how they move objects are very light or
heavy so because if it's a styrofoam
cube you might as well Ram it so without
any adverse effects but if it's a really
solid rock you probably don't want to so
in all these components if you have to
put together in order to build a proper
fully functioning autonomous spaceship
so in terms of the demo this is all I
have so I'm not going not going to show
anything super smart here how this moves
around but I will hopefully convey the
idea that he can have a full-fledged
physics simulation running and to
hopefully mimic a realistic system well
enough to design and build it the whole
thing not surprisingly is power pipe
Eisen and contains all the usual
suspects that it would expect some non
binding there's I'm serum cute and ADA
mongodb what have you and language is
Python 3 just in case anybody anybody
KFC and I picture itself it's not going
to go into very into too much detail
should fairly high level overview it
tends to help if you know about terry
pratchett's discworld over because all
the terms that i use or all the modules
that i have i named after characters in
there the important thing about it is
purely that every arrow that you have in
this in this diagram would be
full-fledged TCP connections so the
whole back end is really a network of
microservices all of them stateless so
you can really run them on individual
own independent machines so all of them
you could distribute on a cluster as
large as you want you can create as many
instances as you want and the way to
connect as I mention is either yr 0 and
Q clients so there would be everything
but javascript or by our web sockets
which is probably only javascript for
whom that is important and that's
already it so in summary as well itself
it is not a game engine so it should
feel a bit like one it should behave a
bit like one but it is really meant to
be a
reality environment where you can build
design engineer and experiment with
physical physical system how to control
them and how they intake so in the main
purpose or the sole purpose of this
whole project was to make the standard
classical engineering topics as
accessible as soft engineering is today
and that would be really so if you have
any question or if you want to see the
code anything that's on my github
repository if you have any questions are
feel free to shoot me an email and just
as the last thing that I will plug in
here is since no one pays me to do any
of that so if you think this is cool or
useful in for whatever reason and you
could be bothered to give me as down
github for it there will be really
awesome thank you very much